Oh
it began out of a workshop held at one
of the early women's liberation
conferences this one at Emmanuel College
in Boston and a group of women meeting
at a workshop entitled women and their
bodies decided to continue to meet they
had been talking about hot topics around
sexuality in healthcare and of course
you have to understand that several
decades ago we had no information at the
lay language level for women about
women's health care very minimal
information about sexuality we were in
the dark ages and these were
college-educated women who met at this
woman's liberation conference kind of
astounded they could be so ignorant
about basic bodily functions and out of
the continued meetings grew this group
that became known as the Boston women's
health book collective originally there
was no intention to write a book it was
a gathering of women in their homes and
community centers they began community
courses no your body kind of courses and
they developed these mimeograph papers
that they produced and shared with one
another and kept shining in every time
they prepared something on a topic they
went account we medical library at
Harvard Medical School they talked to a
few of the physicians and more nurses
who are willing to share information and
the end result was this melding of not
just the information one might get from
a medical textbook but the real lived
experiences of women who listen to this
information and they rewrote these term
papers there's no better term for it and
they included the experiences of women
who chimed in and said well you know
this happened to me that happened to me
and they dealt with everything from the
experience of postpartum depression
which of course didn't even have a
language for it then they were dealing
with the fact that some of them have had
illegal abortions and what that was like
that they couldn't get contraception
that they had childbirth experiences
that were really quite traumatic and did
they have to be that way and it didn't
matter what the experience was or what
the topic was what they realized is that
they needed to share their stories share
their knowledge as women and then take
that to other women to expand the
discourse and of course the mini odd
papers became this little newsprint
booklet that the New England
repress put out in late 1970 the title
Our Bodies Ourselves actually did not
come into being until early 1971 and we
are about to be introducing the ninth
edition of the book in late 2011 during
the 40th anniversary a year and we've
seen the book undergo many changes take
on new topics and of course we have a
great deal of advocacy and educational
work we do in addition to this book in
our related books that have we've
produced over the years but we see
ourselves very much as part of the
women's health movement that grew out of
the second wave of feminism late 60s
early 70s and we have been a pillar I
would say in that movement and the
movement has certainly grown globally
our connections are with women across
the globe and one of the ways that
manifests itself today is in our
translation adaptation program we call
it our oboes global initiative and we
have active we are actively working with
about 10 groups in other countries
producing their own translations and
adaptations of material in Our Bodies
Ourselves sometimes it's booklets
sometimes it's a whole book and
sometimes it's simply posters on a canoe
transport system somewhere in Nigeria it
really varies in terms of how the women
take this content and adapt it for their
own use
well back then about 40 years ago there
was very little information in lay
language and we had to turn to largely
health care providers and mostly our
doctors to try to get information and
there was tremendous sexes and
paternalism and condescension within
medicine so it wasn't a great place to
turn to get questions answered it was
always considered inappropriate you were
speaking out of turn so we had educate
ourselves that was number one but number
two there was also a great deal that was
done in the field of women's health and
medical care
that wasn't evidence-based as we'd call
it today it was simply because that's
what physicians did they thought it was
the right thing to do there was no
evidence basis for it so we had lots of
unnecessary hysterectomies even then
unnecessary cesarean sections although
the problem is much worse now and we had
overuse of certain prescription drugs
like mood altering drugs in those days
we had valium and Librium things like
that that were misused that were not
understood to be addictive that women
didn't have good data on so that women
couldn't make good decisions about
whether or not to undergo this surgical
procedure take this drug or follow this
treatment that was recommended by one's
physician so we were in this vacuum and
we were among the first calling for more
research on women's health issues of
course but we realized that we often
were the best experts from our own
bodies and that we needed to understand
better how our bodies function and what
we were going through at any given point
so back then it was a there was a
knowledge gap there was also a dearth of
information and there was also this need
to really learn to be assertive and
learned to speak up so as the early days
of the women's movement and many women
were socialized to be demure to not
speak up to not rattle the cage totally
inappropriate when it comes to getting
good health and medical care so we
needed to change the socialization of
women that was a big tall order over the
years however as we grew and as we
produced more editions of our book we
recognized the need not just to
demystify health and medical care and to
understand certain things but to
move on to get a closer alliance with
public health and that's when we really
started to work with epidemiologists and
to understand better that it isn't
really through medicine that we achieve
good health and well-being it's often
they would improve measures in public
health and its really the food we eat
the air we breathe the water we drink
and also the level of violence in our
streets in our immediate community that
ultimately have the greatest impact on
our health and of course poverty if you
want to look at determinants of good
health and well-being poverty is the
single most important determinant so if
we could work on profit poverty with
reduction we would probably do the most
to improve women's health and well-being
so all these issues kept percolating up
where we were working on the environment
working in workplace safety issues
working on simply D medicalizing many
aspects of women's health that had
become more and more medicalised over
time why were we doing so many
hysterectomies why was the cesarean
section rate skyrocketing and all of
these interventions going a pace without
improvements in outcomes and that's
really the telling story and then along
the way we started tracking something
that is probably one of the most
important elements in health and
medicine today and that is the
increasing and an inappropriate
influence of the pharmaceutical industry
over physician prescribing practices and
physician behavior and also the public's
belief in drugs as the first and only
solution some time to a host of medical
problems and issues that come up in fact
we have something called disease
mongering today a term used to connote
how the drug industry creates conditions
for which it will then market products
and these are not necessarily conditions
that are true medical issues or diseases
they're simply orchestrated and in and
artificially created conditions for
which we now believe we need medical and
drug solutions